I'm about to get surgery I feel like
eyelashes are something I don't notice
but when they are more defined I'm like
oh there's something different about you
today I have two younger sisters and I
just want to experience like what they
went through I'm a beautiful boy okay
everything is perfect on me except for
my eyelashes so if I can accentuate that
watch out I'm Kourtney Castro I'm from
gby Beauty the lash extensions are prior
to the medical grade adhesive but stay
for the eyes the benefits of lash
extensions they open up your eyes it's
less maintenance you always look
beautiful
and your lashes look sick so I'm seeing
my girlfriend this weekend so I'll think
you have more natural look I don't want
her to break out with me we'll keep them
flirting so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna have you look back at me so I can
apply this gel pad to keep the bottom
lashes down don't open until I tell you
to open them which is gonna be like an
hour from now
yeah about an hour all right so here we
go ready all right so to do this you
have to be ambidextrous I dip it in the
glue find a lonely little hair and then
I just apply it to it I read online is
gonna hurt it should not hurt it's
actually rather relaxing just a few more
and we are good to go all right
Oh honestly I never see my eyelashes
it's definitely much more feminine than
I'm used to but that's not necessarily a
bad thing like I could be a kpop star
right now I look like an anime character
good tell ya they're very dark oh my
goodness those are beautiful thank you
this eye is more prominent that I owe
you like no no no way really her first
reaction was pick him off and give him
to me
you don't realize like how much such a
small difference can make they weren't
as life-changing as I thought they would
be and I did feel a little bit more
confident in my eyelashes I can see why
people want to do this because it was
nice having something that stood out I
did feel like my eyes were just pop it
left and right they were I think both of
our eyes were just popping I mean yours
were exploding you guys are seeing this
on the screen he looks like he's like
wearing some [ __ ] well Maybelline [ __ ]